La pregunta es, ¿está la economía china
cerca de experimentar una enorme crisis económica
y financiera? ¿Puede el conocido como modelo
chino llegar a colapsar?
Queridos amigos, amigas, en 2020 el gobierno
chino se las prometía muy felices, el país
había hecho frente a la guerra comercial
desatada por Donald Trump y fue uno de los
primeros países en contener la pandemia del
Sars-Coronavirus-2. Incluso a pesar de ser
el origen de la propia pandemia, la economía
china tuvo uno de los mejores desempeños
del mundo.
Sin embargo, desde entonces las cosas han
cambiado casi por completo. Fijaos.
N1 (15 de julio del 2022: El crecimiento de
China se ralentiza bruscamente, poniendo fuera
de alcance el objetivo del PIB. Bloomberg)
Durante el segundo trimestre del 2022 la economía
china apenas creció un 0,4% respecto al mismo
trimestre del año anterior. Fue, salvando
el coronavirus, el peor dato de los últimos
30 años y pone contra las cuerdas el objetivo
del 5,5% de crecimiento que el gobierno de
Xi Jinping se había marcado para todo el
año.
Y es que, olvidad todo lo que recordáis sobre
los éxitos de China, porque ahora el escenario
es completamente diferente. Desde la segunda
mitad del 2021 se ha ido formando en el gigante
asiático una especie de torbellino económico:
El desempleo juvenil está a punto de superar
la cifra del 20%.
La actividad comercial se ha frenado hasta
el punto de que en términos reales las ventas
minoristas están en negativo.
Los precios de la vivienda llevan cayendo
desde el verano del 2021.
Y para colmo, tal y como podéis ver en pantalla,
la fuga de capitales del país se ha disparado,
comiéndose con ello gran parte del enorme
superavir comercial que sigue teniendo el
país.
C1 (China está en problemas. Lejos de los
titulares de Taiwán, las salidas de capital
son ahora tan grandes como cuando el susto
de la devaluación del RMB de 2015/6. Esto
se debe a la fortaleza del dólar [...] y
a que los inversores extranjeros miran a China
bajo una nueva perspectiva tras la invasión
rusa de Ucrania. Robin Brooks, Economista
Jefe del Instituto de Finanzas Internacionales)
Incluso, el crecimiento de la que ha sido
una de las joyas de la corona de la economía
china se ha volatilizado. Fijaos.
De hecho, gigantes como Alibaba, Tencent o
Didi, entre otros muchos, están llevando
a cabo una enorme cantidad de despidos…
En parte por el mal momento económico y en
parte por la presión ejercida por Pekín
sobre estas empresas ha dañado su rentabilidad.
N2 (Las grandes empresas tecnológicas de
China están despidiendo a miles de trabajadores.
WSJ)
El caso es que este panorama le ha obligado
al gobierno a pedir a las grandes empresas
públicas y al propio aparato del estado que
contraten a más jóvenes para que las cosas
no se escapen de control. Pero eso no parece
sino pan para hoy y hambre para mañana.
Quizás la única buena noticia que ha tenido
la economía china durante el primer semestre
del 2022, fue que, a pesar de todo, la inversión
extranjera directa se incrementó con fuerza.
Pero como veís son muchos más los datos
negativos… Qué los positivos.
Así que la pregunta es, ¿Hasta dónde llegan
los problemas de la economía? ¿Por qué
las cosasparecen tan preocupantes? ¿Qué
tan cerca estamos de un posible colapso? ¿Qué
piensa hacer Xi Jinping para evitar que China
sufra su primera gran crisis en más de 50
años?
Pues… Atentos.
(¿HASTA DÓNDE LLEGAN LOS PROBLEMAS?)
A contracorriente con el resto del mundo,
a mediados de agosto del 2022, el Banco Popular
de China decidió reducir los tipos de interés.
N3 (15 de agosto del 2022: China da la sorpresa
con una bajada de tipos mientras los datos
muestran una desaceleración "alarmante".
Bloomberg)Y no solo eso, sino que al mismo
tiempo el gobierno anunció un incremento
del gasto público.
Un momento, ¿menos tipos y más gasto público?
Esto quiere decir que el gobierno chino se
comporta como si el país estuviera ya en
crisis, e incluso, en recesión. … Qué
por otra parte es lo que también nos dicen
los datos que vamos conociendo.
Y es que, a ver, saber exactamente lo que
ocurre en China no resulta nada fácil. No
hablamos precisamente del país más transparente
del mundo. Sin embargo, la situación parece
incluso peor que lo que refleja el crecimiento
del PIB estimado por el gobierno.
Pero claro… Hablamos de China. Un país
que oficialmente no ha experimentado un crecimiento
negativo ni tras la masacre de Tianament,
ni en la crisis financiera del 97 ni tampoco
en la del 2007. Así que el hecho de que China
haya publicado practicamente su peor dato
de crecimiento de los últimos 30 años ya
nos dice mucho de cómo están las cosas:
no precisamente bien.
Pero… Ahora bien, realmente ¿hasta dónde
llegan los problemas de China? ¿Cúales son
los mayores “agujeros” que hoy por hoy
tiene la economía de este país?
Pues, bien, prestad mucha atención porque
estos son los 5 grandes grandes problemas
quehoy por hoy complican el futuro económico
de este país y la posible respuesta del gobierno
para intentar revertir los malos datos que
hemos visto.
(El primero de ellos tiene mucho que ver con
el propio funcionamiento básico de la economía
china. Y es que veréis, mientras que en la
mayor parte del mundo el PIB es una medida
de lo que se ha producido en un país durante
un periodo de tiempo, en el caso de China
la cosa es algo distinta.
Sí, el PIB mide exactamente lo mismo, pero
la diferencia está en que es un indicador
determinardo políticamente con antelación.
Es decir, el gobierno fija un objetivo de
crecimiento y luego impulsa a todos los actores
públicos y privados a intentar alcanzarlo.
Es el efecto directo de la planificación.)
Y os preguntaréis, ¿y dónde está el problema?
Pues basicamente en que cuándo los funcionarios
creen que no se va a alcanzar ese crecimiento
ponen sobre la mesa todo tipo de tretas y
medidas para intentar conseguirlo. Por ejemplo,
se lanzan como locos a construir infraestructuras
y todo tipo de proyectos, hacen que las empresas
públicas se pongan a contratar como si no
hubiera mañana. Y también expanden sin frenos
el crédito, por ejemplo para que las familias
compren más y más viviendas y esto impulse
el crecimiento. Todo con tal de alcanzar el
objetivo.
Para colmo la inmensa mayor parte del sector
bancario en China es público, es decir, trabaja
para cumplir los objetivos del gobierno. Y
si hace falta más crecimiento pues se ponen
como locos a conceder nuevos créditos…
Incluso aunque se los den a personas o empresas
con dudosa capacidad de pago. No importa,
tienen que cumplir sí o sí con los objetivos
de concesión de créditos marcados por el
estado para que estos a su vez ayuden a lograr
los objetivos de crecimiento. ¿Veís dónde
está el problema?
En cualquier caso, durante años esto no fue
estrictamente un problema porque China estaba
infrainvertida: tenía pocas infraestructuras,
pocas empresas y pocas viviendas. Así que
todo lo que se hacía era tremendamente productivo.
Sin embargo desde hace unos 10 o 15 años
la situación ha cambiado por completo.
China ha construido tanto que, por ejemplo,
las nuevas infraestructuras o la ampliación
de capacidad de las empresas públicas. pues…
Ya no son rentables. Es decir, no generan
retornos suficientes como para compensar toda
la inversión realizada. ¿El resultado? Una
enorme espiral de deuda. Fijaos.
La deuda en China ha crecido tanto que tan
sólo entre los años 2007 y 2017 se multiplicó
por 4, lo que supone un incremento mayor que
el de cualquier otro país. De hecho, en términos
de PIB los chinos tienen hoy más deuda circulando
que los propios Estados Unidos.
Y, ¿Sabéis qué? Esto nos lleva directamente
al segundo problema. Mientras la deuda ha
crecido mucho, la productividad - que al final
es lo que determina en gran medida la capacidad
de pagar esas deudas - se ha desplomado.
Esto hace que China tenga que invertir muchos,
muchísimos recursos para mantener el crecimiento.
Inversión que se financia con deuda y que
sin embargo genera pocos beneficios.
Y queridos amigos, amigas, ¿qué ocurre cuándo
tu deuda se dispara, su capacidad de pago
se reduce y encima tu economía entra en crisis
y pierdes ingresos? Pues… que tienes un
problema. Y sobre todo, tus bancos tienen
un serio problema. ¿Por qué? Pues porque
puede que muchos de sus créditos entren en
mora, es decir que los deudores no puedan
devolverlos.
Y justo este es el tercer gran riesgo al que
se enfrenta la economía china: la posibilidad
de sufrir una enorme crisis financiera.
Ahora bien, sobre esta cuestión en concreto
hablarán muy pronto y con todos los detalles
en Si lo Hubiera Sabido, el canal de información
financiera de Mutuactivos con el que participamos.
Si aún no lo conoceis os dejo por aquí abajo
el link para que le echéis un vistazo y si
os gusta os suscribais. Por ejemplo, así
podréis saber exactamente hasta qué punto
China puede estar cerca de sufrir una crisis
financiera.
Bien, luego junto a estos 3 grandes problemas
se suma un cuarto muy relacionado con ellos
y con todo lo que os hemos contado: la implosión,
el reventón del mercado inmobiliario.
(El sector inmobiliario chino es gigantesco.
Para que os hagáis una idea, tan sólo en
2021 se vendieron en China 2,4 billones de
dólares, billones hispanos, de viviendas.
Directa e indirectamente este sector supone
casi el 30% de toda la economía china. Así
que poca broma. Hablamos de uno de los principales
motores económicos del gigante asiático.
Pues bien desde el verano del 2021 las cosas
en este sector van de mal en peor y tanto
la inversión, como la venta de viviendas
como los precios se están desplomando.)
(15 de agosto del 2022: Bomba de relojería":
la crisis inmobiliaria en China se agrava
al caer los precios de la vivienda por undécimo
mes consecutivo. Fortune)
Y eso no es todo. Capital Economics, una consultora
con sede en Londres, apunta que a finales
del 2021 en China había aproximadamente 30
millones de propiedades no vendidas y cerca
de 100 millones más que estarían vendidas
pero no ocupadas.
Y evidentemente suponiendo una parte tan grande
de la economía china, el reventón del sector
inmobiliario es algo que potencialmente puede
ser muy serio para la economía china.
El desplome de esta industria podría provocar
cientos de miles, millones de desempleados,
el colapso de muchas promotoras, muchos más
problemas para los bancos y un empobrecimiento
general de los chinos por la pérdida de valor
de sus propiedades. Pensad que las casas forman
la mayor parte del patrimonio de las familias
de este país. Y si su precio cae, de repente
estas familias con hipotecas enormes a sus
espaldas se vuelven de repente mucho más
pobres.
La situación es tan delicada que vídeos
como este se han hecho virales en las redes chinas. Fijaos.
Por supuesto no parece que haya margen para
que eso pueda ocurrir… Y tampoco parece
algo aconsejable.Fijaos.
Pero… Seguimos. El 5º problema que China
tiene por delante tiene mucho que ver con
la guerra de Ucrania.
(La guerra comercial iniciada por Donald Trump
y la creciente beligerancia de Pekín dio
la señal de alarma para muchas empresas.
Ahora la invasión rusa de Ucrania junto a
la política covid cero del gobierno chino
han vuelto a poner sobre la mesa el riesgo
geopolítico y la importancia de asegurar
las cadenas de suministro.
Esto puede hacer que durante los próximos
años muchas multinacionales trasladen parte
de sus operaciones -o al menos concentren
sus nuevas inversiones- fuera de China. Esto
es algo que todavía no ha ocurrido pero sí
se sabe que las empresas están preocupadas.
Así que si finalmente se frena la inversión
de las empresas extranjeras en el país, esto
podría suponer un duro golpe para el crecimiento
económico de China. Es decir, podría dificultar
seriamente la recuperación.
Y para colmo, en un plazo inmediato, la crisis
energética internacional podría terminar
causando una caída en las exportaciones chinas
que agraven aún más los problemas económicos
que ya tiene este gigante)
Y luego, por último, aunque no sea algo que
vaya a tener consecuencias en un futuro inmediato
a medio y largo plazo sí que tenemos que
tener en cuenta la cuestión demográfica.
China está envejeciendo a toda velocidad.
De hecho, es muy probable que la población
en edad de trabajar ya se esté reduciendo.
Qué es exactamente lo que también ocurrirá
con la población del país durante los próximos
años. En esta línea, en 2021, las tasas
de natalidad chinas cayeron a un mínimo histórico.
Evidentemente, una población más pequeña
y más envejecida se traducirá en más gasto
público, menos dinamismo económico y una
deuda per cápita más alta.
Pues bien, el caso es que estos 5 grandes
riesgos - o 6 si incluímos el declive demográfico
- pueden suponer un frenazo, un serio viento
de cara para el vuelo económico de China.
Si no se gestionan bien, estos problemas pueden
incluso terminar provocando una enorme crisis
económica y financiera en China.
Así que la pregunta, ¿corre el llamado “modelo
chino” el riesgo de colapsar? Y la pregunta
quizás ahora mismo más importante: ¿Qué
demonios piensa hacer el gobierno de Xi Jinping
para revertir esa situación?
Pues bien, veamoslo.
T2 (¿EL GRAN FRACASO DE XI JINPING?)
Vale, ya sé lo que muchos estáis pensando…
A ver, Enrique…. Todos los países experimentan
en algún que otro momento crisis económicas,
monetarias y financieras…. Desde Estados
Unidos hasta la Unión Europea pasando por
Japón o Corea del Sur. Y ni hablemos ya de
América Latina.
Entonces, ¿no es algo exagerado hablar del
posible colapso del modelo chino porque unos
cuántos datos económicos no marchan bien?
Pues sí…. Y al mismo tiempo no.
(Desde hace décadas el modelo chino ha consistido
en garantizar una rápida mejora en los niveles
de vida a cambio de que los chinos no cuestionaran
el gobierno y el poder del Partido Comunista.
Digamos que ha sido algo así como una especie
de acuerdo tácito, no escrito, que ha legitimado
a los gobiernos chinos. Y fue así durante
los mandatos de Deng Xiaoping, Jiang Zemin
y Hu Jintao. Para conseguirlo la apertura
y la integración de China en la economía
mundial fue algo imprescindible.
¿Os acordáis de esa época, cuando los mandatarios
chinos aparecían en las televisiones de los
hogares estadounidenses recitando a Lincoln
y deseando la amistad entre los pueblos?
Sin embargo, las cosas han cambiado y aún
siguen cambiando con Xi Jinping. Desde que
el actual líder se hiciera con el timón
en el 2012, el gobierno empezó a intervenir
más en la economía, el crecimiento se ha
desacelerado y además, para intentar mantener
tasas de crecimiento más altas, la deuda
de las empresas, de las familias y del sector
público se ha multiplicado.)
De esta forma los datos se han ido poco a
poco deteriorando. Y aúnque, sí, China tiene
muchas fortalezas, lo cierto es que la prosperidad
explosiva que durante años ha caracterizado
a este país ha desaparecido.
A Xi Jinping le importa mucho más el control
social, político y económico del Partido
Comunista que el nivel de prosperidad. Así
que, digamos que con él China está frenado
en seco su apertura. Incluso, se está haciendo,
otra vez, más totalitaria. Con todas las
cosecuencias que eso tiene.
Pero, sea como sea ahora la pregunta es, ¿Qué
diantres piensa hacer el gobierno chino para
evitar la crisis? Pues… Probablemente tirar
de las viejas recetas de siempre. El problema
es que esta vez pueden no ser sufucientes.
Por un lado, para evitar las crisis, el gobierno
chino siempre ha recurrido a los estímulos
fiscales y sobre todo a los estímulos monetarios.
Es decir, expandir el gasto público y aumentar
mucho la concesión de crédito.
¿Recordáis que China ha bajado los tipos
de interés? Pues exactamente eso. También
han aprobado grandes líneas de préstamos
para las empresas y están reduciendo los
requisitos para comprar viviendas.
En el pasado esto ha funcionado. Sin embargo,
lo hizo a costa de incrementar mucho la deuda
en circulación… Y ahora ya parece demasiado
alta como para que estas políticas puedan
tener mucho más recorrido. De hecho, durante
los últimos meses la oferta monetaria ha
crecido mucho más rapido que el stock de
crédito. Y eso es lo que explica noticias
como esta:
(“Los nuevos préstamos bancarios de China
caen más de lo esperado en medio de los nervios
inmobiliarios. Reuters)
Además, bajar tipos cuándo la Reserva Federal
está haciendo exactamente lo contrario puede
aumentar la salida de capitales del país.
Luego, por otra parte, el presidente Xi Jinping
ha pedido un esfuerzo de todos los actores
públicos para aumentar el gasto en infraestructuras,
y que estás puedan convertirse en una especie
de amortiguador económico ante el frenazo
del sector inmobiliario.
(14 de julio del 2022: China prepara 1,1 billones
de dólares para apoyar el impulso a las infraestructuras
de Xi. Bloomberg)
Sin embargo, un momento, porque no resulta
tan sencillo. ¿Por qué? Pues porque una
de las principales fuentes de financiación
de los gobiernos locales y regionales es la
venta de tierras y los ingresos procedentes
del sector inmobiliario. Y, ¿Sabéis qué?
Las ventas de tierra se han hundido un 30%
en 12 meses. Esto es lo que explica que estos
gobiernos hayan empezado el 2022 emitiendo
deuda a un rítmo récord para financiar todo
tipo de infraestructuras, como, por ejemploo,
parques industriales, redes de transporte,
proyectos de agua, redes móviles o centros
de datos.
Lo que nos vuelve a llevar directamente al
problema que veíamos antes: Xi Jinping trata
de mantener el crecimiento económico de China
a base de emitir deuda y construir infraestructuras
que no son rentables porque la mayoría de
ellas no se necesitan. Y cómo no son rentables,
una vez que se terminan de construir ya no
aportan crecimiento a la economía…Pero
la deuda y los intereses se quedan.
En resumen, puede que China siga teniendo
muchas fortalezas y muchos sectores que van
viento en popa. Sin embargo, su situación
macro se ha ido deteriorando y mucho durante
los últimos años. Ahora el país parece
a punto de enfrentarse a una crisis económica
y quizás financiera sin que esté nada claro
cómo espera el gobierno afrontarla. Porque
tal y como habéis visto puede que esta vez
las recetas de siempre no funcionen.
¿Puede significar esto que la época de gran
crecimiento chino ha llegado a su fin? Pues…Ojo
que cada vez más analistas apuntan a esta
posibilidad. Proximamente en Si lo Hubiera
Sabido nos darán muchos más detalles sobre
esta cuestión.
Con todo, quizás el mayor problema es que
Xi Jinping quiera compensar el peor rendimiento
económico con un nacionalismo mucho más
agresivo. Y eso, eso sería malo para todos.
Pero llegados hasta aquí, turno para ti:
¿Creés que China terminará sumergiéndose
en una dura crisis económica o por el contrario
creés que logrará sortear todos sus problemas?
¿Crees que puede colapsar el llamado “modelo
chino”? ¿Qué hará Xi Jiinping para afrontar
todos estos problemas?
Como siempre déjanos por aquí abajo tus
comentarios y darle a like si este vídeo
te ha resultado interesante.
Muchas gracias por estar ahí.
Un saludo y hasta la próxima.